hey guys it's max we just got into brand
new iPhone se 2 as I want to call it and
today we not only going to be taking a
look at it we're also gonna be comparing
it to the iPhone 11 and the iPhone 10
are we're gonna look at a wide variety
of things including things that you
can't just figure out by the spec sheet
such as the displays we're gonna look at
the speakers we're gonna take some
photos and we'll see which one of these
you should spend your money on
now all these phones do come with your
regular ear pods and then a 5 watt
charger and all of them do support 18
watt fast charging if you want to buy
that separately now let's go ahead and
peel this off it is very weird to hold
another tiny little iPhone I know if you
guys have the original iPhone se it's
not that small but for me using these
larger phones it is definitely small but
you guys can see the difference it's
very interesting this red almost looks
kind of pinkish let's see yeah you can
you guys see the difference there that
is a very interesting this 10r is also
the product red and it's a deeper richer
red than the SE now I also notice
obviously this thing is really really
lightweight visually doesn't look that
much thinner but in your hands you could
definitely tell this thing is incredibly
small I basically don't even feel it in
my pocket and I don't remember what it
was like to use such a small phone so
the next difference is we have touch ID
now I really really like face ID both
iPhone 10 are in knife own eleven
feature that now right now if you're
covering up your face that's one area
that the touch ID does work better at I
love being able to just flick up and
you're there on the home page it is a
little bit faster actually I may be
wrong maybe it is faster just to press
and be logged in automatically I mean
that is pretty quick they're both pretty
quick one thing you can do with the 10r
and the Eleven is just tap to wake up
the phone whereas with the SE it will
erase to wake but tap to wake doesn't
work now that it's on let's compare the
displays so you guys see there is a
massive difference now with SE we have
this really big bottom chin
and then we have that forehead there
whereas with 11 and the 10r we have this
fairly thick bezel that runs all the way
across on the sides on top of the phone
and then we have the face ID cut out
this is 4.7 inches compared to 6.1 and
you guys can see the difference in real
estate of course the benefit of that is
that I can actually reach pretty much
everywhere I can pull down to get my
lock screen over here and then for
control panel you actually pull up just
like the older iPhones and then for
multitasking you do a double click with
the 11 or the 10 are I can kind of shift
it or around and reach up here but
definitely is a stretch but I do really
like the multitasking how Apple designed
it and then just being able to flip back
and forth between apps it is really
quick now the SE screen has a lower
resolution but because it's smaller it's
actually just a sharp and detailed at
326 pixels per inch as far as brightness
and contrast they are rated all
identical but if we look at these
side-by-side it actually looks like the
iPhone 11 is brighter
let me grab the iPhone 10 are let me see
that again
does the se actually look slightly
brighter what do you think yeah it looks
slightly brighter to me even though
they're rated the same so it looks like
the SE is brighter than a 10 R but the
11 is slightly brighter than se with it
being smaller lighter and thinner than
the iPhone 10 R and 11 I'm wondering how
do the speakers compare so put on your
best pair of headphones and let's take a
listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you guys go ahead and let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below I'll give you guys my opinions and
I guess I should have expected it it
sounds like old iPhones used to sound so
it's not terrible but it definitely is
quieter than the iPhone 11 and the 10r
has less bass it sounds more like
popping sounds and then the biggest
thing that really stood out to me is it
doesn't sound as even when I'm holding
it in my hands I hear a lot more from
this bottom firing speaker than I do
from the front facing speaker Apple have
really improved that with the latest
phones I know the iPhone 10 also had
that where it was not balanced so if
you're looking for a great experience to
watch different movies go on YouTube
definitely the iPhone 10 or 11 is going
to be better because the larger screen
and the better speakers now not
everybody watches a bunch of videos on
their phone but most people do take
photos and this is a really big strong
suit of the iPhone se let's go ahead and
just compare the camera both with the
10r
these cameras are actually identical but
the SE has newer hardware and software
for the CPU so it's interesting to see
the difference in camera bumps the whole
circle is actually smaller and then if
we look at them side-by-side it this is
the camera bump doesn't stick out as
much it's around more rounded and with
softer edges and that's interesting
because the phonus thinner and the
camera bump is smaller compared to the
10r
comparing it to the 11 this has this
much larger camera module and it has an
extra lens but Apple did actually really
make the camera bump really minimal as
far as how much it sticks out very
similar with the S II even though the
sensors here are different now flipping
around to the front side I've heard a
lot of people mention that the 7
megapixel camera of the iPhone se is the
same one that's on the 10r just like the
rear cameras are the same but it's very
interesting that if I go to video tab
over here the SE will only let me do
1080p 30 frames per second whereas the
10 R allows for 1080p at 60 and that
leads me to believe that the cameras are
different because the processor in here
is faster than the 10 RS and then if I
grab the iPhone 11
this thing will actually allow me to
shoot 4k 60 with the front-facing camera
you can actually go wider if you have
more people to fit into the frame which
is nice the other two can do that and
this guy is a 12 megapixel front-facing
camera now here are three just regular
selfie shots side by side without the
wide mode you can so let me know if you
guys see any differences now even though
the iPhone se doesn't have the whole
sensor or rate like we have in the 10r
and an 11 Apple still allows you to use
the selfie portrait mode option which is
very interesting and here you guys see a
comparison between them and even though
the camera likely is even older than the
iPhone 10 ours you see that the software
differences try to make up for some of
that and with the 10 ARS photo it's
using older software you guys see my
shirt is all blurred out whereas on the
SE 2 and the 11 it's not now another
difference between these cameras is that
the iPhone 11 can take portrait shots of
regular objects so you guys see this
lens is blurred out where on the other
ones it's not and with the iPhone se or
the 10 art if you try to do a portrait
shot of anything else you just get this
little notice as no person detected
Apple allows you with the SE to use all
of the effects for the portrait shots
but they don't give you that on the 10r
and the iPhone 11 is the only one that
has night mode to take nighttime shots
which is very weird for me this is a
software thing the se could have had it
there given you other software features
and even the portraits front-facing
selfie mode is all software we're not
using the hardware like another - why
not allow the se to have night mode as
well and the last difference I want to
cover is the ultra wide lens that is
included with iPhone 11 it's not a
necessity really I mainly use the
standard lens but it is nice to have
sometimes here's what it would look like
in the situation I personally want to
use it here but it is nice I'm going to
be doing a full comparison between these
cameras and taking a much more detailed
look at the differences in software and
hardware so make sure you guys are
subscribed so you guys don't miss out on
that video and now for what's probably
the most exciting thing about the iPhone
se and that is that it has Apple's best
processor the same a Thor
tene Bionic that is in the $1100 iPhone
11 Pro max and if we compare it to the
10r this has apples a 12 processor in
one difference we do have between the
iPhone 11 is that iPhone se and 10 are
they both have one gig less of RAM but I
have Geekbench Drive open in front of me
so let's go ahead and run our cpu test
now the 8:12 in the iPhone 10 are isn't
about processor but the 813 it is faster
it is more efficient and you'll know
that with this processor you're gonna
have at least five years of software
updates even though this phone costs
less money so the iPhone 10 are took way
longer to finish and you can see that
the SE single core performance is
getting close to being double of the 10r
and the multi-core is also much much
higher and the SE pretty much matches up
with the iPhone 11 so that is a big
difference in CPU performance in as far
as graphics performance once again the
iPhone se is close to twice as fast as
the 10r and it actually slightly beat
out iPhone 11 now that is a massive
difference in performance now I know
people are buying the se they probably
don't need that much but what that means
is that if you keep your phone for a
long time your phone is still gonna be
fast years from now now let's talk about
battery life even though the a13 is more
efficient than older processors Apple
still rated the SE the same amount of
battery life as the iPhone 8 the battery
in here is quite small I mean I do
expect to do a little bit better in the
real world but it still will not compete
to the iPhone 11 and the 10 are these
ones are much bigger they have much much
bigger batteries and you are gonna get
one to two hours extra of screen on time
depending on what you're doing
compared to the s II so if you're
somebody that loves to be on your phone
all the time if you're watching a lot of
videos listening to music you're playing
games stuff like that then it's nice to
have the larger screen of the iPhone 11
and a better battery life and if you're
somebody they just want the phone it's
gonna last a while take great images be
very comfortable in the hand have that
great processor that's where the SE
really shines so where does that leave
the
10r it costs $200.00 more than that s e
but it's much weaker in terms of CPU and
graphics the camera quality isn't gonna
be as good at has less features there if
you don't really care about performance
you just want to watch videos and have a
larger screen to surf the web Facebook
stuff like that it might be a nice
middle ground but for only $100 more you
can have that same 813 Bionic the ultra
wide lens the better performance of the
iPhone 11 so I think overall it's
probably a toss-up between these two
phones and when you put the price points
into put into perspective $700 versus
400 this is just such a good value so if
you don't mind the size of the display
and the speakers and not having the
ultra wide lens you really can't do much
better than this it does have the older
design you have touch ID but you have
that processor in the updated cameras
and you get to use iOS let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below if you guys want to see the camera
comparison make sure you guys click that
circle above to subscribe and while
you're at it if you want to see another
couple great videos we have them right
over there
this Ben Max and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]